welcome to this video a five minute game
on icc and i'm playing in the national
master from Italy it's it's a real name
is Carlo de Mora and he's a very good
blitz player but he tends to have a very
yeah his rating is going up and down all
the time he's also around with 2,500
often so is very low rated for a
strength okay we get them Kings Indian
here if you had shuttle system and I'm
playing this line with c6 and Queen f5
it's ad free solid line couple of
teammates played this some years ago
this why I know roughly what what is
what's going on I think it's a bit more
dangerous for black and white doesn't
play 25 but then also this should be a
slight advantage for wide with them to
bishops anthem especially the space
advantage what black is trying to do
here he tries to later exchange the g7
bishop so I'm making room here for the
Queen to go back to d8 and then prepare
something like we never ate Bishop h 6
s's one idea getting rid of them the
bishops and then trying to play with two
nights against them potentially bad
bishop on f3 but um it's only really am
potentially week it's not really a week
peace
white can activate and not not not so
much now but white or sometimes has the
idea to play h4 and then Bishop g2 h3
where it would be a pretty nicely
positioned uh-huh it's interesting it's
not really am trying to prevent this
Queen Medea but I can also play King age
7 bishop age 6 s's maybe even even the
more interesting way to do it yeah he
will play Bishop g5 this is clear yeah
black is fairly solid but it's not the
most active position still I'll play a
bush of 86 the problem after this is if
you place Bishop g5 i'm not sure that i
really want to take on g5 and it's not
so easy to determine how to continue in
this kind of position with a bishop on
h6 end Bishop 135 / wide maybe I can
click King g7 this is interesting
preparing a doubling on the seafoam
maybe the AL candy too I need to do this
anyway otherwise the salt said I
wouldn't make any sense I just took okay
yeah the idea was to UM speed up this
doubling on the C file so i can play
rook c7 and rook c8 it's no no big deal
could have thought about Roxy fraud so
look D for being a possibility mm maybe
I should have invested a bit more time
okay it's I don't have any any problems
here ready Queen a five I really
overlooked Queen a five year but I can
play be six hopefully yeah I can play be
six pack the songs bit lucky I'll be six
what sort of physics okay can return and
this is a weakness yeah I see ya don't
have any choice so exchange or Quincy
eight Quincy it could be better yeah
let's play coed so that i can let up
that i'm on the sea far yeah I have to
say six weakness which is some a bit of
a sorry a bit of a shame
yeah well I want to allow Quincy 60
let's grab it so yeah Bishop to e2 EMS
may be coming next I don't want to play
a five on this but b5 is also not the
move you really love to play okay let's
go here first be 584 before yeah I need
to do this so yeah they fall so before
I've got 95 later yeah he also has ideas
of the kingside was g45 must be M must
be careful this position looks rather
harmless but it can get down can get
problematic really quickly yeah I'm not
before huh so should I cover this with
knife ba gia what should I do probably
am trying to activate the King here yeah
it's very difficult to make any kind of
progress yeah it's probably intending a
form led to be 6 out of play yeah not a
5c six also
a possibility but i don't i'm not sure
what this is doing them yeah some it's
not very active and basically just sit
and wait yeah this one my feet take
scientist guy we get c5 mmhmm yeah
probably so try for this i will have
night c4 if it takes as a counter play
idea the tickets a three point k didn't
didn't move yeah so it's simply not a
good position what can you do yeah we'll
lose on time but the position is also
very bad yeah lets you form so last kind
of little hope yeah i can just stay put
oops Nick they are camping this was
probably jack yeah it was just um just
perfect I'm hi I'm just bad for me this
is position it's just bad for me yeah
it's all night so silly pieces sometimes
they don't have any any outposts yeah i
mean this b6 move is really a really a
shame that you that you need to do this
i mean i can ma'am maybe well maybe I
should play 98 year this is really a
huge difference this b6 move that's now
in this kind of position this is Bishop
you see to bishop um I mean I only can
play moves I don't want to play a 5 is
bad b5 is bad night pietas ma'am also
ugly I will thinking about this even but
it's just it's just ugly in this
position of the Queen side and he ODS
always has this ideas of attacking the
pawns in the long run and I simply have
no no active play at all maybe I should
have tried to prepare our no f5 or
something but it sets it simply it's
simply bad so yeah you cannot do much
really okay this isn't great here what I
did but it said simply I'm simply very
uncomfortable this position you can
certainly defender bet I am no no
question
maybe and maybe I should really still
play five year but yeah no way I can
just play Knight c3 and window b5 porn
yeah what can you do it's just them
adjust them very very uncomfortable to
play yeah thanks for watching